hi
if you
win this game i'll give you
20 subs
wait was he is he pogging are you
pogging sir
[Laughter]
hello
oh my goodness hey nico
um
you are
the uh
you made that bernie sanders tick tock
like a year and a half ago that got
really really really popular
possibly
and
nico
you played in pogchamps 3
i tried to play
my best i just wanted to say
it's great to have you here
i don't think you played in pogchamps 4
though
right i did not i don't think you did
i did not
um
take my challenge
okay we'll play knight b5 so if i win
this game
you will gift 20 subs subscribe do i
still take your challenge nico
tried to play my
no you did great you did great nico if
you want to watch
any
analysis if you're still interested in
chess i don't know if you're still
interested in chess
the fact that you are on this stream i
presume that
uh that you at least have some interest
in chess still
so if you want to watch
an analyses of any of
your games
there's my pogchamps 3 playlist you can
check out
he's all like
i'm not going to lie he's adorable he's
like got this if you would like
i think i'm going to check out his
channel come on you can do it 20 subs my
guy you okay asr
go easy my man
okay i'll check a tiny dancer still
still
still going strong okay
you guys think he's one he subs he's
awesome yeah he's so wholesome he's like
my playlist
it's adorable
do it for nico nico is streaming
are you serious
you can do it you can do it you can do
it thank you thank you so much
um
okay we'll play knight fd4
what's the idea with this move
okay i'm gonna hope that our opponent is
not watching the stream so this is a
viewer
so
it's very possible they are watching the
stream at this moment
so i've actually i don't want to say
anything
nico
i would love to explain this move to you
and your audience you can just you can
do the best
try to explain
my idea with this knight fd4
it's gonna be up to you
it's like very it's very intellectual i
think he thinks i'm smarter than i am
see if you can uh thankful thank you so
much for being here nicholas thank you
so much for giving thanks thanks for
watching
i love you
all right
so we'll play knight take c6 now
and now nico
what move are we gonna play fork
you already know it don't you
fart we've got the horsey fork
the horsey fork inbound and we don't
even get to play it because our opponent
resigned
good game asr
great game to you
whoa
he won guys
he resigned what up oh yeah nico thank
you so much for the congrats
as well and nico
gifting 20 subs
thank you so much nico
thank you so much i hope
you were you're getting some good
content for your stream right now
adorable i'm not even gonna lie he's
adorable i just wanna i just wanna like
i just wanna like chess big brain nico
hey
if you wanna play a game i'm down to
play a game
with you right now if you're interested
if you're busy
and you're doing something i totally get
that i have to catch you again some
other time you you made my night so i
want to thank you thank you again peter
donated
thank you so much